what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
story lines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on uh later on in this
channel okay so as promised we get into
the origin of x23 and I feel like maybe
I've done this before but I think it's
like one of my older style videos where
they were like super boring and scripted
those videos suck instead we are going
to do this fun so uh x23 is origin story
is rooted in like the cartoon show
really X-Men evolution I mean she first
popped up there Craig Kyle and Chris Yos
made her everybody loved her and so
Marvel was like well let's throw her in
the comics now she did appear in NYX and
I feel like NYX was part of Marvel's max
line of comics at least I certainly hope
it was because x23 the way she appeared
in that story was anything but a
character designed for kids but with
regards to innocence loss this is like
her first in the main Marvel continuity
story and really if you wanted to pick
up with x23 this would be the place to
go I mean you could read x23 volumes 1
and 2 probably the X force and then just
kind of go from there uh really all new
all different Wolverine is a great place
to start but the idea here is this will
essentially give us everything that we
need with regards to this story now what
this does is this picks up with regards
to uh The Escape of of Wolverine
remember we talked about that in our
video on the origin of a Wolverine's
adamantium again you'll find that down
in the description but we had talked
about how when Wolverine was taken into
the Weapon X Program he was uh basically
had adamantium bonded to a skeleton he
was trained to be a killer eventually he
escaped well what this does is show us
the multifaceted ele of his Escape in
the sense that it wasn't just him
breaking out of the facility killing a
handful of professors and then just
riding off into the sunset well it
wasn't really the sunset it was kind of
in the snow and you know it was nasty
outside but it was it was basically him
just kind of getting away from this
horrendous experience he was having what
we also do is we pick up with a guy by
the name of Dr Rice now uh this guy is
essentially one of the multitude of
people who were killed by wol rain but
the issue here is that at this point
wolver rain's still very animalistic in
terms of how he functions and in terms
of how he operates and so because of
that by killing this guy Dr Rice wol R
just basically takes off and leaves
everything there but what this does is
this sets the stage for a man by the
name of Martin Sutter to essentially go
back home to Dr Rice's family meet with
his son Xander provide him with the dog
tags of his father say I'm sorry the
worst thing you feared has happened and
basically take him on as his own now
several years later and we're kind of
left to believe this is something like
20 odd 20 some odd years later we pick
up with Xander rice with the
continuation of this Weapon X Project
now that's where we get into things
because remember following the Escape of
wolver rain and the fact that his his
skeleton was bonded with Adam antium he
had a healing Factor it was like the
Great Space Race right I mean everybody
wanted to get their hands on wolver rain
or have something like him that's one of
the reasons why he's always been such a
popular character and he really was up
until the expansion of the weapon x
project uh during Grant Morrison's run
of the X-Men that's why Wolverine was so
popular because he was an anomaly he was
like the one guy that had adamantium
claw the one guy that had an adamantium
skeleton he had a healing Factor he was
for all intents and purposes
indestructible and so because of this
with wolver having the abilities that he
does people were trying to form their
own Weapon X programs now some
individuals did this or some companies
did this and even some countries did
this for the purpose of just having
their own version of Wolverine with
regards to what's going on here with
Martin Sutter and Xander rice they're
doing this for profit and that's kind of
the ironic thing about all this is
because they they're basically doing it
for money now with Xander rice
undergoing this most recent experiment
to basically try to clone Wolverine
ultimately it's not working and that's
really the inherent difference here when
it comes to these different variations
of of trying to duplicate Wolverine the
example of like dead pool for instance
it was the idea of bonding Wolverine's a
healing factor to other people or trying
to bond adamantium and ultimately it
just didn't really work the way it was
supposed to with what Martin Sutter and
Xander rice are doing here they're like
we don't need to bond adamantium to
people we just need to clone Wolverine
if we can clone him make a perfect clone
then what that means is we can literally
use this clone to do what weapon x was
originally supposed to do and this makes
sense because remember the weapon x
project was in the 1960s this is you
know 40 years later or 20 years later
whatever is 1980s 1990s the result is
that technology is more advanced now
than it was back then and so because of
this there's a lot more stuff that they
can do they can bring in psychics to
mess with the mind of the Wolverine
clone make him do what they want him to
do there's a lot of different things
that they can uh they can engineer here
in order to make sure that this
Wolverine clone is docel the problem
with this is that every time they try to
clone him it just doesn't work now in
terms of why it's not working is
revealed to us with the introduction of
a character by the name of Sarah Kenny
now Sarah Kenny is much like Mora mcag
in Marvel Comics so just to say where
moral metager is one of like the the
leading geneticists when it comes to the
idea of of mutants within the Marvel
Comics Community this character Sarah
Kenny is very much the same way just
with a more updated version with a more
updated version of a character in the
sense that her speciality is biology and
cloning and so the idea is if Xander
rice can't get it right then maybe Sarah
Kenny can now of course this creates a
rift between the two of them in the
sense that Xander rice looks at Sarah
Kenny as a person that's trying to take
over his role right I mean like like he
was he's basically the Protege he's like
the the adopted son of Martin Sutter and
then suddenly this woman Sarah Kenny
comes in and she's going to be the one
heading the program now now of course
with with regards to sarakan analyzing
these things what we end up finding out
here is that the the genes themselves
are are basically screwed up the genes
themselves are not what they're supposed
to be and so it's like trying to make a
cake with only half the ingredients you
just can't do it and so because of that
Sarah Kenny says we only really have one
option the only option that we have here
is to basically replace you know replace
the uh the Y Gene with an X Gene
basically turning what would be a man
into a woman now something else that I
want to draw your attention to is the
idea that Xander rice is basically
sleeping with the wife of Martin Sutter
now that's not why wildly important
right now but it will be important later
on down the line but of course when
Sarah goes to Martin Sutter and says hey
look this is the only option that we
have we have to create a clone of
Wolverine with the XX Gene instead of an
XY Gene making him a woman instead of a
man Xander rise freaks he's like no it's
supposed to be Wolverine it has to be
Logan and the reason for this isn't just
because of the fact that he's trying to
assert his dominance the idea is to
basically be duplicitous to trick people
because remember if there's a Logan
running around out there right now and
then suddenly somebody says hey I just
saw wolver rain assassinate the prime
minister of some country somewhere well
well then people are going to say well
what's we do we really have two
wolverines in the same you know two
wolverin running around the world it
creates a really confusing situation for
everybody but the idea here is also that
in the end Sarah Kenny doesn't care she
says look I'm here to do a job and I'm
going to do that job to the best of my
ability even if it means going against
everything that I've been told so far
and so what happens is Sarah Kenny ends
up going to Martin Sutter and saying hey
look I did my job all right I made this
clone of wol rain I violated your orders
not to make it a female I went ahead and
made it a female anyway we now have a
girl clone of wolver rain and the works
now of course where Xander freaks Martin
suter's just like hey we have a job to
do and so he tells her go through with
it find a surrogate mother for this this
clone that you're making well then of
course we have Xander rice going to
Sarah Kenny and it's like guess what
you're going to be the surrogate mother
now again this is part of that whole you
know that whole Rift between the two of
them in the sense of Xander rice is
basically going to make Sarah Kenny
carry of this girl to term now it's not
like Xander rice walks in and says
you're the surrogate mother and leaves
what he does is he more or less
blackmails her he says look you're
effectively engineering a child from
scratch you're playing God you know now
what you can do is either you can carry
this child to term or I can kill it but
whichever one you pick it's going to be
on your head now of course this is him
screwing with her head but at the end of
the day Sarah Kenny says Okay and she
basically allows herself to be
impregnated with Laura Kenny with x23
now at this point going forward things
get really really dark and the reason
why well not super dark but things get
really screwed up for Laura Kenny the
reason why is because she was created to
be a killer at this point it's out of
Sarah Kenny's hands her job is done she
was the one that was there to be the
biological engineer behind x23 you know
Sarah's just kind of kept on board
because you know it works and so the
idea here is almost immediately after
she's born going you know 7 years later
on she's just basically trained non-stop
in martial arts she's trained on how to
be an assassin now this is why I say
that when people make that argument of
x23 versus Wolverine things get
interesting things get kind of
intriguing and the reason why is because
of the fact that in some ways x23 is
better than Wolverine in other ways
wolver rain's better than x23 x23 does
not have the experience that Logan has
she just hasn't been around long enough
she didn't have the experience that
Logan had when he was part of Team X she
doesn't have the experience he had when
he escaped from the facility joined the
X-Men went on to become part of the
Avengers she doesn't have any of that
instead all she has is the seven years
of training but it's seven years of some
of the most advanced and some of the
most honed military training and uh and
and martial arts training that a person
can receive she is essentially the
perfect weapon now the crazy thing about
all this is that this situation also has
Xander rice basically making life hell
for for Laura Kenny and the reason why
is because of the fact that Sarah is
very nurturing with regards to her
daughter she teaches her she reads to
her she basically tries to help restore
her Humanity because that's the whole
thing is x23 is Humanity has essentially
been Stripped Away that's really this
whole idea in addition to that it's
other people like her Sensei her martial
arts master trying to reconnect with her
Humanity trying to keep what's left of
her Humanity alive the fact that Laura
keny hasn't really been human in the
sense that she hasn't received external
stimulus she hasn't developed friends
she hasn't developed relationships
things like that is something that could
you know inevitably work on behalf of
Xander rice if his mission comes to
fruition but by way of the Sensei and
Sarah trying to focus on the humanity of
x23 in order to basically keep her
around what it does is it allows her to
basically kind of walk this fine Edge
between becoming an animal that doesn't
do anything but kill and trying to
become some measure of a human being now
because of the fact that Xander rice
looks at the death of his father as
something that was engineered by wolver
remember Dale rice the father of Xander
was the one who was killed by Wolf Rain
he Harbors a hatred for x23 I mean she's
the 23rd attempt at cloning Wolf Rain
that's why she's called X 23 but because
of the fact that she's here Xander rice
looks at her as someone that he can
basically take his frustrations out on
now he doesn't do anything extremely
heinous in terms of you know violating
x23 or anything like that but what he
does do is he basically forces her to
endure all different kinds of torture
the first of this comes in the form of
her healing factor and the reason why is
because her healing Factor hasn't
manifested yet and that's one of the
frustrations that Xander rice is having
is by now her healing Factor should be
there but it hasn't and so the idea is
let's jump start it let's force her body
into a situation where her either
healing Factor will will manifest it'll
respond or she'll die so they literally
just start blanketing her in radiation
of course her healing Factor kicks in to
preserve her and that that really just
kind of goes forward into the next stage
which is giving her adamantium this is a
huge difference between x23 and and
wolver rain with wolver rain his entire
body was bonded with adamantium his
entire skeleton was bonded with
adamantium with x23 it's not that way it
was supposed to get to that point and
we'll find out why it doesn't in this
video but at the moment her claws are
literally pulled out of her body with no
anesthesia she feels all the pain Xander
rice dips them or at least he sharpens
them dips them in adamantium and puts
them back in she's made to feel the full
pain of all of this in addition to this
because of the fact that she's very much
like Wolverine she has a feral State now
when it comes to Wolverine entering his
feral state it can be done in a
multitude of different ways but it's
very similar to Thor's Warrior Madness
in the sense that Wolverine can just be
overcome with emotion overcome with like
anger rage something like that and he'll
literally just enter an animalistic
state where all measure of higher
thinking goes right out the window and
he's basically like a Rabid wolf
attacking everything he sees now there
is some measure of a connection those
who are extremely close to him or
individuals that he won't necessarily
attack he'll simply just run away or
something like that like a again like a
like a feral dog but with x23 what has
to happen here is basically a trigger
Cent has to be issued and that's
something I'd like you to keep in the
back of your head but what happens is uh
is is Xander rice basically imbus this
trigger sent onto the sword of x23 and
the reason why is that wither Sensei
basically being one of the individuals
is trying to help restore her Humanity
during one of their training sessions
x23 lashes out because this trigger sent
goes into an animalistic State and kills
her Sensei now again one of the things
established here by Craig Kyle and Chris
yoss is that much like wolver rain when
she goes into this animalistic State
when this trigger s activated she
doesn't necessarily remember everything
that goes on but again we jump forward
by about 3 years when we're basically
left to believe that Sarah Kenny's still
around here she's still an important
part but she's really the last Bastion
for x23 maintaining her Humanity
everybody else is gone the sensei's gone
on it's just the entire facility and
then Sarah Kenny so because of this
Laura has been receiving a multitude of
of assignments that is to say
individuals she's supposed to
assassinate and she's given a watch for
the time that is say it's supposed to be
like 22 minutes between the time she
receives this the time that she goes out
the time that person dies and the time
she gets back now keeping her on a short
leash is extremely effective and the
reason why is because waste not want not
when it comes to the character of x23
one of the first assassinations that she
gets is a guy named Greg Johnson running
for president she gets in there she
poses as a handicapped child just by
virtue of the fact that it would create
good press the uh the campaign manager
of Greg Johnson says bring that girl in
here you know let's parade her out in
front of everybody we can take pictures
so on and so forth make our candidate
look good that's just the opportunity
x23 needs in the span of 3 or 4 seconds
she kills not only presidential
candidate Greg Johnson but his entire
family his entire you know everybody
that's with him his entire uh campaign
staff the Secret Service agents that are
there to protect him everyone that's in
this room dies and this all happens over
the span of about 22 minutes between the
time she got the mission and the time
that she got back now this was really
just designed to be an advertisement
it's really all Martin Sutter and Xander
Xander rice were doing is they were
saying hey look to everybody who's who's
listening to as part of this thing you
know whether it be somebody like Red
Skull whether it be you know Dr Doom
whether it be Kingpin it doesn't matter
he they're basically saying hey look
what I offer you is a contract killer
she's owned by us you can rent her out
you can pay for her Services you'll pay
us $6 million $10 million whatever it is
that you want but she'll kill anyone
anywhere no matter where they happen to
be it does not matter now the crazy
thing about this is Sarah continues to
try to tap into the humanity of x23 but
in the end it doesn't really seem to
matter she shows no external stimulus
she shows nothing to indicate that she
values saken that she sees her as a as
like a mother that she sees her as a
friend all she does is take the mission
and these missions take her everywhere
she kills uh she kills royalty she kills
kings and queens she kills Godfathers
you know she kills uh drug lords I mean
she kills anyone and everyone she even
goes against the hand now the reason why
Craig Kyle and Chris yoss included the
hand in here was to prove a point within
the realm of Marvel Comics the hand and
of course if you're watching the
Daredevil Netflix series you'll be
familiar with them but the hand is a
mystical group of ninjas based out of
Japan but they're basically almost
believed to be unstoppable if the hand
come for you then you better get your
Affairs in order that's it you know if
if if the hand are coming for you then
then that's it then you're done you're
you're basically over with they're so
good at what they do 23 is better and
it's just pointing out the idea that she
can take on a contingent of the hand and
hold her own perfectly well what we also
find out is with regards to Xander rice
sleeping with the wife of Martin Sutter
she becomes pregnant now again this
shows us the darker side of Xander and
the sense that he's not just angry at
x23 he's angry at the world he's one of
these guys that has some anger over
something and just can't let it go one
of these toxic human beings and so
because of this that when Martin suter's
wife goes to Xander and says look I'm
pregnant he says then tell Martin it's
his child do not come to me with that do
not come to me with your problems I
don't care if I father that child it's
not mine now at this point we end up
picking up with Xander with regards to
one of the missions of x23 and what he
does is he basically leaves her behind
that's the worst thing about this when
he sends her on the mission she's
successful in completing it she does
exactly what she's supposed to do but
Xander rice tells the pilot leave he
kills everybody on board basically
eliminating all the witnesses and leaves
x23 behind essentially saying I don't
know what happened to her as far as I
know she died and that's really it but
in in the end he's basically getting his
revenge on wol Rain by way of x23 now of
course the cool thing about this is that
it doesn't work and the reason why is
because when he gets back to the
facility he tells Martin Sutter well you
know I mean she died but I mean we can
just recreate her we can just make a new
one you know but then ultimately she
shows up she comes back she literally
infiltrates the facility and she comes
back now of course the question that's
being asked here is what in the heck
happened I thought you said she died but
she's just kind of like you know nobody
nobody knows what how to respond here
nobody knows what to say but what we
also get is this small little instance
of humanity in her it's a little it's
visceral you know it's it it really kind
of yanked at the heartstrings but what
what's what Laura Kenny's been doing
what x23 has been doing is whenever she
commits her assassinations she she cuts
herself she puts x's on her arms now the
reason for why she does this in
particular is not revealed in this story
Instead This is just Craig Kyle and
Chris y saying see there's some measure
of humanity there there is some measure
of humanity in this little girl and
Sarah Kenny seems to have been the only
one that kept this candle going now at
this point we basically pick up with
Sarah grabbing 23 for her own purposes
and the reason why is because uh Sarah
Kenny's sister calls and says hey look
my my daughter's gone I have no idea
what happened and so what Sarah does
here is basically use x23 for her own
reasons now the irony about all this is
Sarah Kenny basically said look what
Martin Sutter what Xander rice those
guys are doing that's wrong they should
not be using you for their own purposes
but then she turns around and does the
same thing the difference here is the
motivation it's the idea of consequence
versus intention you know if you have to
take a moral stance which one do you
take do you focus on the idea that your
intention is to bring harm to another or
do you focus on the idea that your
action is good but it unintentionally
brings harm to another person in the end
it's really just this idea that Sarah
Kenny is doing the right thing uh for
the right reasons I mean she literally
takes x23 she basically gives her the
scent of uh of of her niece and then x23
just starts tracking the little girl
down to the home of a guy now of course
when x23 gets there she just pretends to
be a little girl selling Girl Scout
cookies and this is when we find out
this guy isn't necessarily VI violating
these young girls but he is murdering
them he's actually been killing about
seven different girls over the over the
span of of some measure of time I don't
think we're given a window but uh when
when x23 gets in there you know she's
like hey would you like to buy some Girl
Scout cookies now I love this little
segment and the reason why is because
she opens the box and it's a picture of
the girl that this guy kidnapped and
he's like what the hell is going on x23
throws him out a window now if it were
me I wouldn't have been so light I would
have I probably would have tortured that
guy for two weeks and I would have given
him a blood transfusion if I had to but
x23 decides to give this guy the quick
way out throws him out of a window guy
falls to his death and the niece of
Sarah is rescue now following this all
hell breaks loose and the reason why is
because of the fact that Martin Sutter
is ready to go I mean he's done he's
like look I've been part of this racket
for for years and years and years I'm
ready to retire I'm ready to call it a
day he basically leaves everything
behind to Xander rice Xander rice goes
back to his car when x23 is brought back
to the facility Xander rice goes back to
his car and says your contract is 22
minutes long and your targets are Martin
Sutter his wife and his son now the
reason why this is being done is because
of the fact that the wife of Martin
Suter could bring everything down you
know crashing down for uh for Xander
rice so she went to Martin and said look
you know your child the child that I
told you is yours Henry is not yours you
know you've believed he's yours for the
last three years but he's actually
xanders it could create all kinds of
different problems to say nothing of the
governmental contacts that Martin
suter's built over the years that could
easily see uh Xander rice snuffed out
with no one having any idea what ever
happened to him and so because of this
x23 basically carries out her Mission
with almost Perfection what she does is
she goes in she kills Martin Sutter she
kills Martin Sutter's wife but but she
spares the son Henry again another hint
at this Humanity inside of x23 and
that's what I love about this is because
when you look at her character for what
she does by way of her actions she's
it's like it's like Laura Kenny as a
character is on the inside screaming to
get out but she can't she can't vocalize
her thoughts she can't vocalize her
emotions she can't tell people how she's
feeling all she can do is just show
things through physical action and so
after the mission's over she's taken
back to her containment room she's told
by by Xander rice you don't tell anybody
about this you tell no one what happened
everybody's going to believe that Martin
Sutter and his family died in a fire
just like I told you to make it look
like and that will be that'll be it but
when Sarah goes into the room of Laura
she finds her cutting herself again
another sign that she's committed
another assassination and we end up
finding out by way of Laura Kenny when
she basically opens her mouth and
reveals a piece of paper that she was
sent on a mission to kill Martin Sutter
to kill Martin Sutter's wife and Martin
Sutter's son and so the result of this
is Sarah basically says she ends up
going to confront Xander rice who says
this all stops everything here comes to
an end and I love this because it's
almost almost like something that should
have happened so long ago but it's Sarah
finally saying this is done this is over
we're not playing this game anymore so
what ends up happening is Xander rice
says fine if you want out you can be out
you know if you want to be done you can
be done I mean I'm going to get rid of
x23 she doesn't matter we've got
containment cells filled with people
just like her we've got embryos growing
all over the place because we're going
to make an army of these assassins and
I'm going to make a ton of money off of
it and so of course you know stroking
her hair rubbing her face more or less
intimidating Sarah Kenny he says look
you know you can be part of this or you
can be out of this but if you're out
you're out forever and so what ends up
happening is Sarah Kenny says okay this
this is about it she basically just kind
of calls and quits writes a letter to
her child you know and intends to
basically go and uh and get x23 out of
there but one of the last things she
does is she gives x23 a contract and the
contract is for x23 to kill Xander rice
now this is where the story gets so good
I mean it's kind of weird it takes it to
about the end before it gets incredible
but with Xander rice you know with with
his whole idea of uh of basically trying
to run this show on his own what he's
failed to take into account is that that
at her base core Laura Kenny's human and
she remembers everything every single
thing one of the first things she does
is go into the containment room with all
these different vials all these
different you know uh these different
fetus that are being created for the
purpose of engineering more versions of
x23 and annihilates them all and kills
every single guard in there and what
comes after this is a blood bath on her
way to Xander Xander rice she kills
everyone and I mean everyone like anyone
she comes across as part of the facility
dies scientist military officer Soldier
it doesn't matter every last one of them
dies she finally comes across Xander
rice and she basically starts to beat
the hell out of him right I mean you
know Z like she's able to to easily
topple him because Xander rice failed to
take into account the idea that x23 has
it out I mean with every punch with
every hit with every assault that she
makes on him she flashes back to him
calling her an animal you know for for
him getting his revenge leaving her
behind you know all these these horrible
things that he did to her she remembers
them all and she's taking out every last
one of them with every punch she makes
ultimately leaving him behind with the
build building exploding and so once we
get around to her escape and her more or
less reuniting with her mother or at
least Sarah Kenny having the intention
of taking x23 with her what we find out
is that when Xander rice was stroking
the cheek of Sarah he was planting a
trigger scent and just like she did with
her Sensei x23 lashes out and kills
Sarah Kenny and it's one of the saddest
things to see because it's just like
it's it's it's so crushing because she
basically tells she tells Lura she says
look you know you're my child your name
is lore this is the first time in the
comic that she actually gets a name but
she says your name is you're my child
you're not a monster you are a child you
are not some object to be used by other
people you're a kid you have to
basically live your life and so what she
does is she essentially just kind of
bails out she ends up making her way off
and this basically leads to where
introduction as part of the X-Men and so
on and so forth coming across Wolverine
for the very first time which is a uh
which is a really really cool story in
terms of how that unfolds but yeah guys
if you are new here to Comas explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rcore if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like I me this is the origin of x23 and
it's one of my favorite stories with her
character and she really only gets
better in her own volume right up until
the end adventures and babysitting get
weird as hell but um but in any event
yeah we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you guys later
[Music]
peace